why are why are there it seems like
there's
everybody lives in tampa every
wrestlemania why because of the weather
right
the weather sucks here it's so hot they
like it
wait you you don't know what it's like
to live up north
yeah that's true you have to put clothes
on to go outside you come inside you
have to strip off
when you go outside you have to double
up close
you have to double up everything so is
it because all these wwe wrestlers
they've been exposed to every country
every city on earth and they've they've
found that tampa is by far the best
and you know forward to just florida in
general the tax laws and everything too
the tax laws are way better here for
sure yeah they're cheap too and if you
go into bankruptcy
you um you still keep your home in your
car
oh yeah do a lot of wrestlers go
bankrupt no i've been i've been down
there
in the restaurant that dead one on dale
maybe i come back and it was three
quarters of a million
in debt i went overseas for i went
overseas
and stayed up in the middle east but
this is after wwf
and i came back and it was 780 780
000 in debt i had to go bankrupt there
who the hell did you have run in that
operation i don't know that suddenly two
people had
the the um to the back door
and um the time i got back and then they
said to me everybody was coming in
we're open from 11 to 12 11 a.m to 12
p.m
midnight and they were going out and
after midnight and partying on the strip
and that you know all the restaurants
the city bars down around there
and coming back we sold lobster street
you know filet mignon and all that [ __ ]
and um they were taking out
the cube rolls slobs the tails and
drinking the alcohol
just partying there they just [ __ ]
they were going out of five
because because i went to the company
was doing the um
the service for us and they they gave me
the sheets and they said
this is what's been happening
everyone had the key code anyhow get
back to wrestling
so anyhow that was that that's crazy man
yeah anyhow after you only come into the
states that's when i got into the
booking side of it
you know my first territory is a book if
you know what a booker is
the booker is the guy that runs the back
of the house for the promoter
and that the arresting promoter
does a promotion books the arenas
has the television and does all that
sort of stuff you know he doesn't
right but the booker writes the
television and
brings and books the talent and lays out
the matches
and writes it and writes the television
show and i yeah and i started doing that
in 83.
okay and i did that right up till i went
into wwe
and when i got out of wwe and in two
and 201 i went down to puerto rico and
ran a company with
iwa there to 208
and i had all latins there here i am an
english-speaking person
and i have three latins working for me
oh my god
puerto rico and it was telemundo first
we could have we could use other we
could use other music
you know any music and that and um we
could use
you know the rock songs and all that
sort of stuff and then telemundo was
brought out
by nbc and then we had to tighten the
whole show up
you know it had to be right on the
second for for commercial breaks
nowhere to play we had to buy uh generic
music
and they had to change the the whole
front of the thing who was the guy that
got murdered in puerto rico
bruja brodie bruiser bro and his wife is
a kiwi
i still talk to barbara on the internet
you do really his wife his wife is from
new zealand yet
wow yeah lanie was talking a little bit
about that yeah he was a good friend of
mine
he drew a lot of money with me with
abdullah the butcher did he really yeah
absolutely and andrew they were the
biggest stars in japan ever from
what they say is that he was like a
big-time bully like he bullied people a
lot or he was like
well unless yeah yeah not like not like
in the ring but like behind the scenes
he was like kind of a dick and kind of a
bully to people that's what
that's what i've heard from like
documentaries about him and that's yeah
that's a i know him from a different
point of view he was well when he went
when
when he got booked to go work in the
territory he went there to get over
as the bad guy yeah and he got over
straight away because if you
if you don't get over you don't draw any
money he was always main event
and now he's gonna hill's got to get
over because
the bay the good guy's gonna have
someone to beat you know there's always
a good guy in the territory
hello the local good guy you know what i
mean and you feed the bad guys
to him all the time once a good guy bad
guy gets over
he has a good strong run and then he
goes and like you have to get another
bad guy over
and the good guy stays there you know
what i mean right yeah yeah
like jerry lawler stayed in memphis all
those years yes
you know i remember when when um
the guy from taxi he's dead
oh the guy from taxi
came in and that and he was on the david
letterman show
no no remember the show taxi yeah i
remember the show i don't remember
who you're talking about though who was
the mainstay andy kaufman
okay andy kaufman he's the guy who came
in a wrestled woman and that
from new york and that and got over and
that
and then he wasn't bigger than that but
then he did a big program i was there
when
they did the bird jimmy hart was the
main part of this too
did he ever did he tell you about the
andy kaufman thing no oh that was a big
thing david letterman came down
they did the whole big the letterman
show there no way
yeah that's where they did the burning
and that and
with kaufman it was a hell of an angle
an angle is a thing that you do right to
draw
to draw the houses down the line of that
okay
jerry lawlers did a big thing there yeah
yeah so what are you doing now so what's
next so what's uh what's your future
what's the future for the for the
bushwacker well
for the luke to put my matching boots on
a match
just going to march into the sunset no
no i'm not marching into the sunset yet
no i'm going back looks like i'm going
to go back into the um
restaurant bar business are you really
yeah
that's a tough business yeah what i've
heard tough business
tough business i know being there the
gym business also i mean you just got
out of the gym business
i got out of that because of the rent
you know the guy the plaza was
sold and um and then my contract
they raised their price come up and that
and the uh rent was one and a half times
what i grossed wow god damn that doesn't
work the brown box has taken over that
and the japanese restaurant yeah the
brown box is going to put a stairway up
into their front are you kidding me so
they're going to be no i'm not kidding
man that's going to be insane yeah
they're putting a bowling alley in games
room
up top no
oh down below down below you're gonna
dig a hole and go underneath
of course they're putting a stairway up
the top and going straight up
you're not gonna put a bowling alley on
the second floor or even anybody i think
they're gonna put a million and games
and games when you like the tap and
token that they did that did [ __ ] on the
south beach
but they're gonna they've always had the
idea dave and buster
did you do it right that's a good spot
for that yeah
that would be that would be pretty yeah
you know taking that place is [ __ ]
jam-packed every weekend down there in
years now you know that
you know the the hallway there between
the japanese place
and the gym oh yeah that's close going
to be closed off
okay and out of that elevator there and
they're putting the stairway
they're putting the stairway there down
down um
into right into the uh brown box
yeah wow that's insane so that's going
to be
there's a hey that's going to be a a
big job there you know it's going to be
at least
i'd say a half a million to them it's
going to be a million dollar job oh yeah
so where are you working out now that
you don't have the gym where are you i
went there
to there today to the um
to clearwater beach fitness i saw the
name and all the equipment
i sold to the media and all that stuff
everything okay
everything are you still working out
there though i worked out there today
but i've been going to
with hulk to the um goals on um
east bay with hulk yeah okay still
hanging out with hulk a lot
no i haven't been hanging out with them
but haven't seen them you know i've been
on the road
before the gym and that but now i've got
more time
and i'm looking to do something on the
beach and wait for him to open up there
too
see but that's a long job open up you
know hogan's hangout
it's been sitting there ready to open up
for for six months i don't even know
what hogan's hangout is where he's on
the corner
next next the brown boxer in the same
plaza
well they have the beach shop you know
you know the surf shop yeah
they've had that for three years they've
done it all up it's really ready to open
and what's it gonna be it's hogan's
hangout is that gonna be a bar
hogan's hangout what are you doing
you're [ __ ] you're walking and you
hang out what do you do yeah eating
drinks
okay bar restaurant wow
upstairs is open it's got inside out
outside what it's already open
no oh it's ready i'm chomping at the bed
i want to go hang out with hogan yeah
it's been over ready to open for the
last
three months i don't know what the city
is doing
you know what i know that there are a
city water you know what clearwater
beach is yeah
that was three years in the makings they
started doing this three years ago
damn you're behind time what's going on
so is he doing it by himself i mean
who's he who's he got working with him
on is that all confidential or do you
know is he like working with somebody
who's
someone else's he's just giving his name
exactly right like with uh yeah
like hogan's beach yeah yeah wow that'll
be cool i can't wait to check that [ __ ]
out
it's already built and it's got the big
signs up logan's hanging out and all
that would have been perfect right next
to your gym man that would have been so
great right next to you yeah
right at the gym because it would have
been good for traffic but not even great
yeah but they were
this guy as soon as he came and bought
the plaza the word was he wanted
to make it all games uh uh all you know
um food restaurants and games and that
he's got all the all those you know he's
got the plane and all that stuff
the simulation the simulator there's
about three or four of those place
in that plaza now there's three or four
rooms there now really scary
and there's an escape room yeah
what's the name now the pokeball place
and that's there's uh another another
bar there
where they make all the slushy drinks
okay you know
what are they called yeah it's a clear
one it's
so i got the message even though i told
him when he first come here i said a gym
is always good to have there
because it brings people to the plaza
and they then they can eat and get the
hair all the [ __ ] you know
he wanted to get rid of me i used to
drive i used to drive across town i used
to make [ __ ] 20 minute drive almost
every day to go to that gym
i loved going to that gym yeah that was
the last of
and everyone around the country it came
there they come in there and they always
gave me good write-ups
you know it was a i had a 4.9 or 5 star
on google
trip advisor yeah you did yeah you did
you had a great place you ran that place
right that's for sure
yeah and it was 24 hours yup and that's
[Laughter]
it